hey everyone what is going on as you can
tell by the title of this video we're
talking about the all-new Sigma 20
millimeter F2 dgd anti-series lens for
the Sony e-mount and L Mount Alliance
now before we kick things off big thanks
to Sigma Singapore for allowing me to
test drive the lenses having said that
these are my thoughts and my thoughts
only no money has changed hands I'm not
paid for this video in any way shape or
form these are just my opinions and I
want to share this uh my findings with
you all right with that let's talk about
this all new Sigma 20 millimeter F2 lens
[Music]
foreign
let's get into this thing but before we
do a little bit of a side note if you're
into videography right now we are
actually testing out the Nikon z9 we are
shooting 8K for this video on 8K well
except for the b-roll of course my
editor Xeno and Zach are probably
killing me right now but we got an AK
camera we got to utilize it right right
exactly okay enough about that let's get
down to talking about this Sigma let's
here for a second okay 20 millimeter F2
lens now 20 millimeters is a very
interesting focal length it's not for
everybody especially photographers out
there you have to really enjoy shooting
wide angle photography you know and love
that this kind of distortion that it
will give you if you can play with that
you can manipulate that you can get some
you can get some great images out of
this lens however this lens to me is not
just a photographer's lens this lens is
primarily in my personal opinion a
videographer's lens a fantastic 20
millimeter Prime F2 great for a low
light performance that's going to be
great if you're a vlogger it's going to
be great if you need environmental shots
for event videography wedding
videography or you know whatever work
you're doing it's going to be awesome on
a gimbal because it's lightweight coming
in at 370 grams and the Optics out of
this lens are awesome I mean all the I
series lenses from Sigma are really good
of course they are it's like art glass
and a contemporary design but of course
it's got a different kind of design than
just the Contemporary lenses of you know
a couple years ago I like the look of
the I series probably more than even the
art lenses out there in terms of the
build quality and feel it's robust it's
metal the different layers to it it just
looks great on any Retro Camera or small
camera so if you have let's say a7c for
example or let's say the sigma fpfpl
looks fantastic on a74 it's a lens that
has character on the outside of it
inside as well but it looks really great
and it's easy to pack in your bag and
carry around with you anyway let's talk
about what is in side of this lens you
have 13 Elements 11 groups the filter
diameter is 62 millimeters and the close
focusing distance is 0.22 meters or 22
centimeters so you can get some pretty
close uh you know shots with this lens
but the performance is really what
impressed me the most it's very sharp
minimal chromatic aberration
um colors are great out of this it's got
a nice warm tone to it and when you stop
this lens down you know F2 is great but
when you stop it down it is just razor
sharp so if you're if you're doing
architecture photography or even
landscape and you need something this
wide but you want a very sharp lens it's
great at resolving higher megapixels
this is a lens to definitely look out
for but it's about the video it's about
how this captures video in terms of
performance we're going to show you uh
some sample footage in just a bit but in
terms of Auto focusing performance if
you're wondering is there a difference
between native lenses versus uh
third-party lens like Sigma and our
personal experience we try this on a few
different cameras no there isn't it
performs just like a native lens very
fast autofocusing great eye tracking no
issues at all with that and it just
responds very well when it comes to
videos anyway I'm gonna stop talking
right now I'm going to show you sample
footage from some of the videos that
we've taken with this lens as well as
some photos I've taken with it but
before I do here is a message from our
sponsor
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all-new
2022 Titan Evo with its revamped
four-way lumbar system for enhanced back
support
new leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely Frost Bloom the
Titan Evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at seekerlab.co
[Music]
thank you
all right guys just doing a quick
vlogging test for you here with the
sigma 20 millimeter F2 on the Sony a74i
tracking works great uh as you can tell
the framing is fantastic as well I've
got the camera connected to the switch
pod uh tripod sort of hand grip I'll
hold it all the way out here this is
extended bring it back to more of a
comfortable holding length this is it
absolutely fantastic I think this is
gonna be a great vlogging lens for those
who want to get into that
so as you saw from the footage and also
from the photos out there this lens is a
really good performing lens now again 20
millimeters may or may not be the lens
for you that's okay when it comes to
photography but videographers out there
I think this may be a lens to definitely
consider if you're a vlogger as I
mentioned before event videographer
wedding videographer you want a really
good prime lens you want something
that's going to separate your subject
from the background that gives you a
nice bokeh to it that is razor sharp
that's going to allow you to have that
flexibility to crop it if you need to
because of the resolving power of this
lens you're going to be really impressed
with what this Sigma I series lens
delivers those are my thoughts on I like
it I think it's great I didn't think of
it first as a videographer's lens but
after Zachy was using it for a while and
after I played with it for a while I'm
like yeah this is the video lens out of
sigma's I series lineup in my personal
opinion for you know someone you know
below 35 millimeters this is the lens I
would definitely pick up anyway those
are my thoughts on the lens let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below is it you're looking to pick up if
not love to hear your reasons why or why
not for that anyway subscribe to the
channel if you guys can helps us out a
lot we have a lot of great content
coming up here with that take care stay
safe follow us on Facebook and uh we'll
chat to you soon take care
[Music]